you're just going to explain where you
think you won this ward because it might
not this second situation because it
might not be quite the story that's
getting out there yeah I mean in essence
you've got three big parts of the
Russians true constituency Rochester
itself strewed on this side of the river
and then the peninsula which is a vast
area and relatively sparsely populated
Rochester very much the strong
conservative voting area we had a tough
day there yesterday we had a tough day I
mean of course we were getting votes
that we had a tough day
as the kitchen sink was felt was thrown
there what a kitchen sink was thrown
everywhere but we certainly felt there
that the Conservatives were holding on
to their vote and we were we were up
against the most massive machine I mean
with letters from the Prime Minister
passes a telephone calls being made from
America all sorts of things going on and
yesterday they had over a thousand
people out on the ground so you know in
Rochester the conservative vote held up
incredibly strongly more than Clarkson
yes more than klaxon strewed
traditionally very strong labor we did
very well there and and we we pretty
comfortably top the poll in a sense
would you say you wouldn't in strews
rather than Rochester I think the key to
this election for us was picking up a
large chunk of labour votes and we did
that you know the numbers prove that so
that was really important but when you
go there yeah these are voters that
maybe believe in the labor message on
cuts on the cost-of-living crisis - you
were voting for a form of conservative
vote I mean well there but don't forget
that that you're talking here about
people and we've had their wages
compressed you're talking here about
people who have seen their community
change in a huge way in the course of
the last ten years you're talking here
about people who are decent British
people but it were very upset of a
negative impact mass immigration has had
on their lives and they see us as the
only party prepared to stand up and
champion their cause and this is where
the flags were this is where the-- this
is where the crosses and george's were
and there was great anger so we
definitely did very well there and
equally out on the peninsula we did
pretty well they're generally
conservative voting but not as wealthy
apps as the conservative voters in
Rochester itself so you think that this
underlines whilst you know it's 3,000
majority 7% yeah the Conservatives are
arguing we're gonna well we're just
going to win it back at the general
election this pattern might underline
why you think it's going to be a bit
stickier for you than they I think the
Conservatives and to be honest with you
much of the media thought of you hip as
we take conservative votes and that
that's the battle it isn't at all we
take our votes from you know from across
the board we picked up a big chunk of
labour votes in this by-election
yesterday and interestingly we also
picked up a chunk of voters you haven't
paid you for anybody for twenty years so
you know the you keep dynamic is we pick
up seeds across the board and and where
that translates to the next general
election is basically the more marginal
the seat the better chance you keeps go
okay just bit of North Kent is shown
here where else do you think you have a
chance at the general election or via
defect obviously you're modest up around
I so far has been via defection yes I
mean you're gonna be standing in South
Anna which is bit off this graph yeah
it's a different thing isn't it from a
standing start without having that I
think I I think having one in Rochester
and strewed when the Conservatives said
everybody said we wouldn't and reckless
I made a terrible mistake and it was
changes the whole dynamic and I now
genuinely believe today there are a good
number of seats in Kent where we can
potentially win next year and defectors
we see that Adam collarbone was clear
Paula Bowen was chaperoning mark were
close into Parliament today yeah I know
Michael Gove has said today he's a
hundred percent certain there will be no
more defectors personally I would be
very surprised if there weren't more
defectors between now and the election
you talk about a sophisticated
conservative machine that was phone in
from America you're doing the same thing